bien pues estamos en el problema número
12 así que vamos a atacar de una vez
este problema y dice cuál es el mayor de
cinco enteros consecutivos esto creo que
ya lo hemos hecho muchas veces si la
suma de ellos es 185 sí sí sí es muy
típico este problema en los problemas
del s atn así que lo único que va a
estar acordar es el tip que te había
dado si lo que queremos es el mayor de
estos 52 consecutivos pues vamos a
ponerle el nombre el nombre del mayor de
estos 52 consecutivos le voy a poner x
voy a bautizar como el mayor de estos 52
consecutivos como equis y si éste es el
mayor bueno el que le sigue a este es
decir el anterior sería x menos 1 y el
que le sigue a éste sería x menos 2 y el
que le sigue a éste sería x 3 y el que
le sigue a éste sería x menos 4 date
cuenta que aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 5
enteros y los 5 son consecutivos por
ejemplo
aquí tengo 10 aquí tendrían nueve ocho
siete y seis son cincuenta euros y son
consecutivos pero además me dicen que la
suma de estos cinco la suma de estos
cinco es 185 ok entonces cuánto vale el
mayor de ellos pues vamos a hacer lo
cual es la suma de estos cinco sin
pensar en este 185
bueno pues tengo una 2 3 4 5 x 5 x menos
menos 1 - 2 - 3 - 4
es lo mismo que menos 3 menos 6 menos 10
5x menos 10 esto es la suma de estos
enteros consecutivos que por cierto me
dicen que es lo mismo que 185 y de aquí
ya tengo una ecuación muy sencilla en la
cual puede resolver para x 5x es lo
mismo que 195 y ahora está dividido todo
entre 5 me va a quedar que 195 entre 5
es el valor de x y bueno 195 entre 5 lo
podemos hacer pero qué te parece si
pensando
200 200 entre 5 es lo mismo que 40 40 -1
es 39
entonces x es igual a 39 esa es la
respuesta a este problema este es el
mayor de ellos y además te puedo
asegurar que estos enteros consecutivos
es 39 38 37 a 36 ok y 35 aquí tengo 5
enteros son consecutivos y estoy seguro
que la suma da 185
así que trabajemos en el siguiente
problema
no sé si me quedo aquí mejor voy a
borrar la pantalla volvemos la pantalla
y voy a pensar en el problema número 13
que dice el salario base de un vendedor
es de 1200 pesos
ok entonces lo que gana un vendedor lo
que ganan un vendedor va a ser como base
1200 pesos muy bien y después me dice
que a esto le agregan el 20% del precio
de cada artículo vendido a esto le
aumentan el 20% pero recuerda que el 20%
lo podemos ver como punto 20 como punto
20 es firme si mal por la cantidad de
artículos que haya vendido si él vendió
tres artículos pues bueno él se va a
ganar el 20 por ciento de cada uno de
estos artículos y voy a decir que ese es
la cantidad de artículos vendidos en ese
mes ok pero además me dicen que este mes
recibió 2 mil 500 pesos y me preguntan
cuántos artículos vendió es decir que
este mes este mes lo que él ganó fueron
mil quinientos pesos dos mil quinientos
pesos y yo lo que quiero saber es el
valor de ese si te das cuenta si nos
quedamos con esta parte de la ecuación
con esto de aquí de aquí puedo obtener
el valor de s así que manos a la obra
que me queda yo tengo que mil doscientos
mil doscientos más punto veinte por s es
lo mismo que dos mil quinientos 2500 y
ahora qué te parece si resto mil
doscientos de ambos lados de esta
ecuación de tal manera que me va a
quedar que punto 20 s
es lo mismo que 2500 menos 1200 es mil
trescientos mil trescientos ahora hay
dos formas de resolver esto yo podría
decir que ese es lo mismo que 1300 en
3.2 pero como no me gusta hacer
divisiones con punto decimal mejor en
lugar de hacer esto voy a pensar qué
punto 20s es exactamente lo mismo que un
quinto de ese esto ya lo sabemos
un quinto es lo mismo que punto 20
sabemos que de aquí sale el punto
entonces yo lo veo así y me va a quedar
que un quinto de s
es lo mismo que 1300 y ahora qué te
parece si multiplico ambos lados de esta
ecuación por 5 ya es mucho más fácil
resolverlo por 5 este lado por 5 de este
lado y entonces estos dos se van a
cancelar y me queda que s es igual a
1300 por 5 que cuántos eso 1300 por 5
003 por 5 es 15 llevamos 15 por unas 5 y
unas son seis 6.500 este vendedor para
obtener un sueldo de 2.500 tuvo que
haber vendido 6.500 artículos ya está
esta es la respuesta del problema número
13 y bueno pues vamos a borrar la
pantalla para pensar ahora en el
problema siguiente en el problema número
a 14 el problema número 14 que por
cierto tienen una figura la siguiente
figura vamos a hacerlo de una vez
un círculo ok por aquí tengo mi círculo
y después tengo un pedazo de este
círculo
tengo una rebanada de este círculo algo
más o menos así y así y me dicen que
están muchos de 40 grados este ángulo es
de 40 grados ok vamos a ver qué me dice
el problema alma vende joyería hecha con
plata ahora de que padre para un tipo de
arete se cortan uñas de un disco de
plata
ok creo que voy a entendiendo este es mi
disco de plata disco de plata y para
hacer un arete se cortan cuñas de este
disco de plata como a continuación se
muestra en la figura y es esta figura es
decir que esta es una de mis cuñas esta
es una de mis cuñas que voy a ocupar
para hacer los aretes de plata necesito
tener primero un disco de plata y
después cortarlo en
me dice si el peso total del disco de
plata es de 2.5 gramos ok eso es
importante el peso de este disco el peso
de todo el disco es de 2.5 gramos
qué es el peso del disco de plata vamos
a poderlo sacar para no confundirnos es
el peso de este disco de plata lo que
nos preguntan es cuánto mal en cada una
de las cuñas que vamos a cortar ok y
bueno pues este problema radica en saber
en cuántos pedazos vamos a cortar este
disco de plata si cada cuña cada uña
tiene un ángulo de 40 grados cuantas
cuñas me caben en este disco bueno pues
no podemos pensar así este disco tiene
360 grados 360 grados y cada una de las
cuñas me representa 40 grados 40 grados
por lo tanto vamos a ver en cuántas
partes vamos a tener que dividir este
disco de plata bueno
de aquí puedo cancelar esto con esto y
me queda que 4 entre 36 es lo mismo que
1 - estás de acuerdo qué quiere decir
esto que cada una de las cuñas es una
novena parte de este disco de plata o
dicho otra manera a este disco de plata
lo voy a dividir en nueve partes para
que cada una de las cuñas sea de 40
grados ok
recuerda que este disco de plata tiene
aquí 360° 360 grados ok pero yo sé que
todo el disco de plata pesa 2.5 gramos
entonces una cuña es un noveno de esto
que pesa en total el disco de plata o
dicho de otra manera podemos decir que
cada cuña el peso de la cuña déjeme
ponerlo por acá el peso de la cuña es lo
mismo que un noveno por 2.5 gramos uno
ve lo que es lo que representa cada cuña
de este círculo de este disco de plata
por lo que pesa en total este disco de
plata ahora el problema lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que aquí tenemos
muchos puntos así que mejor voy a
ponerlo así un noveno que va a
multiplicar a 2.5 pero 2.5 lo podemos
escribir también como una fracción y el
peso de la cuña el peso de la cuña es lo
mismo que un noveno que multiplica a dos
enteros un medio estás de acuerdo que
dos enteros un medio es lo mismo que 2.5
pero cuando es esto bueno pues esto es
lo mismo que un noveno que va a
multiplicar a dos por dos cuatro más
unas cinco a cinco medios yo sí puedo
concluir que el peso el peso
el peso de una cuña de una cuña va a ser
pues un noveno por cinco medios lo cual
es 5 entre 1850 y 18 es la respuesta de
este problema uno más y veamos dice el
problema número 15 pero número 15 y me
dicen si tengo que x cuadrada que x
cuadrada menos 10 cuadrada esto es igual
a 10 y además que x gent x gent es igual
a 5 ok lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale x menos y en cuanto vale x menos
díaz y bueno antes de pensar en cómo
resolver este problema cuando yo tengo
es cuadrada menos de cuadrada en lo
primero que pienso es en una diferencia
de cuadrados y seguramente por aquí está
la solución del problema de hecho por
aquí está la solución del problema si tú
pues x cuadrada menos de cuadrada y te
das cuenta de cómo son los problemas de
seattle seguramente te van a pedir en
factorizar lo y esto se factorizar como
una diferencia de cuadrados
recuerda que esto es lo mismo que x -
james que multiplica a x + y esto es
igual a 10 ahora lo que está genial es
que me dicen que x + que es igual a 5
por lo tanto esta parte de aquí es igual
a 5 esta parte de aquí es justo esto de
aquí lo podemos sustituir entonces me va
a quedar 55 que es esta parte de aquí
que multiplica a x
james esto es igual a 10 esto de acuerdo
y de aquí para pasar este 5 dividiendo
en el otro lado de la ecuación o dividir
todo entre 5 dividido a esta parte entre
5 esta parte de 35 este y esta semana me
va a quedar que x menos james x - es
igual a 2 que es justo lo que me piden
el valor de x menos james y el valor de
x - james es igual a 210 en 35 es 2 y
así de fácil y de sencillo estaba este
problema así que pues sacamos otro y
bueno como en el siguiente problema
tenemos una imagen bastante difícil de
dibujar qué te parece es mejor lo
dejamos para el sigue
en el siguiente vídeo empezaré con el
problema número 15 hasta luego